welcome to the presentation on basic
edition
i know what you're thinking sal edition
doesn't seem so basic to me well i i
apologize i hope
hopefully by the end of this
presentation or in a couple of weeks it
will seem basic so let's get started
with uh i guess we could say some
problems
well let's say i start with a with a
with an old classic
one plus one
and i think you already know how to do
this um but i'll kind of show you a way
of doing this in case you don't have
this memorized or you you haven't
already mastered this
you say well if i have
one
let's call that a avocado if i have one
avocado
and then you were to give me another
avocado
how many avocados do i now have well it
says you have one
two avocados
so one plus one is equal to two
now i know what you're thinking that was
too easy so let me give you something a
little bit more difficult
i like the avocados i might i might
stick with that theme
what is
three
plus four
this this is i think a a more difficult
problem well let's go let's stick with
the avocados and in case you don't know
what an avocado is it's a it's actually
a very delicious fruit it's actually the
the fattiest of all the fruits you
probably didn't even think it was a
fruit even if you ate one
so um let's say i have three avocados
one
two
three right one two three
and let's say you were to give me four
more avocados let me put this four in in
yellow so you know that these are the
ones you're giving me
one
two
three
four
so how many total avocados do i have now
that's one two three four five six seven
avocados so three plus four is equal to
seven
and i'm going to introduce you another
way of thinking about this it's called
the number line and actually i think
this is how i do it in my head
when i forget
if i don't have it memorized
so number line i just write all the
numbers in order and i go high enough
just so i can all the numbers i'm using
are kind of in it
so you know the first number is 0 which
is nothing maybe you don't know but now
you know
and then you go to 1 2
10. keeps going 11. so we're saying 3
plus 4. so let's start at 3.
so i have 3 here
and we're going to add 4 to that 3. so
all we do is we go up the number line or
go to the right on the number line four
more
so we go
one
two
three
four
notice all we did was just increase it
by one by two by three by four and then
we ended up at 7 and that was our answer
we could do a couple of different ones
we could say what is
what if i asked you what 8 plus 1 is
8 plus 1. well you might already know
you know plus 1 is just the next number
but if we look at the number line you
start at eight
and you add one
eight plus one is equal to nine
let's do some harder problems
and just so you know if you're a little
daunted by this initially you can always
draw the circles you can always do the
number line and um eventually over time
the more practice you do
you'll hopefully memorize these and
you'll do these problems in like half a
second i promise you you just got to
keep practicing
let's say i want to draw the number line
again actually i have a line dual so i
shouldn't give you all those ugly
looking lines that i've been giving you
look at that look at that that's amazing
wait let me see
oh yeah look at that
okay so
let me that's a nice looking line i'm
going to feel bad to erase it later on
let me draw a number line
0 1
2
3
4
5. 6
so let's do a hard problem
what is
i'm gonna do it in different colors now
five
plus
six so if you want you could pause the
video and try this you might already
know the answer
and the reason why i say this is a hard
problem is because the answer has more
numbers than figures so you can't
necessarily do it on your fingers
so let's get started with this problem
actually my phone is ringing but i'm
going to ignore the phone because you're
more important
so
okay let's start at the five
so we start at the five
and we're going to add six to it so we
go
one
two
three
four
five
six
we're at eleven
so five plus six is equal to eleven
now i'm gonna ask you a question what is
six plus five
huh
well
we're not going to see that can you
switch the two numbers and get the same
answer well let's let's try that i'm
gonna try a different color so we don't
get all confused so let's start at six
right ignore the yellow for now and add
five to it
one
two
three
four
five huh we get to the same place
and i think you might want to try this
on a bunch of problems and you'll see it
always works out that it doesn't matter
what order you know five plus six is the
same thing as six plus five
and that makes sense if i have five
avocados and you give me six i'm gonna
have 11. if i have six avocados and you
gave me five i'm going to have 11 either
way
let's do a couple since this number line
is so nice i want to do a few more
problems using it although as i use it
i'm sure i'll just continue to confuse
you because i'll write so much on top of
it but
let's see i'll use white now
what is
what is
eight plus seven
well
if you can still read this eight is
right here
right we're going to add seven to it
one
two
three
four
five six
seven
we go to fifteen eight plus seven is
fifteen
so hopefully that gives you a sense of
of how to do these types of problems and
more than i guess this and you're going
to learn multiplication a little bit
but but these types of problems are when
you're getting started off in
mathematics these kind of require the
most practice and to some degree you
have to start memorizing them but over
time you know when you when you look
back at i want you to remember how you
feel while you're watching this video
right now and then i want you to watch
this video in like three years and
remember how you felt when you're
watching it now and you're gonna be oh
my god this this was so easy because
you're gonna learn it so fast so anyway
i think you have an idea if you don't
know the answer to any of the addition
problems that that we give in the
exercises you can you can press the
hints and it'll draw circles and you can
just count up the circles
or if you want to do it on your own so
you get the problem right you could draw
the circles or you could draw a number
line like we did in this presentation
um
i think you might be ready to tackle the
the addition problems have fun